oh you haven't been doing vlogs lately
I'm gonna unsubscribe this is not the
David I knew what the [ __ ] I'm doing a
[ __ ] blog now know what bouncing out
of you [ __ ] [ __ ] bye Felicia
hey what is going on YouTube now I got a
gym membership for years that's right I
said years [ __ ] never said I used it I
just have it just in case you know
eventually I want to look down and see
my penis but being a comedian being very
observant kind of go hand in hand
because the only way for me to gain life
experiences and get these stories is for
me to go out and experience life so
early on in my life when I figured out
if you ever wanted to collect the
craziest stories you just have to enroll
into a commercial gym commercial gyms
are pipe are the biggest breeding ground
for the weirdest [ __ ] on earth now for
me at least six or seven times in my
life somebody at a 24-hour Fitness has
threatened to whup my ass and just as a
side note every time it happened it was
not my fault proof you asked though
right here I'm fat that's it it is a
known fact that fat people do not start
[ __ ] at the gym because we are too busy
trying to find a way to escape if you
wanted to categorize me in the gym I'm
that dude at the gym that always use the
machines wrong but get mad at you when
you try to correct me where the farm
bales at they're called dumbbells who
you call me dumb [ __ ] what the [ __ ] wow
you're fat and stupid so today I'm gonna
share with you a story about me getting
my ass punk in a gym now a few years
back when I used to live in Koreatown
Los Angeles there was a 24-hour fitness
that I was trying to go to now mind you
this 24 hour fitness I didn't want to go
to because I heard it was ghetto and
number two it was late at night and I
don't like to get robbed and getting
myself titty-fuck by random people
that's just me now recently I heard this
24-hour Fitness cleaned up and it's
actually pretty nice but during the time
that I attended this 24 night time it
was [ __ ] dangerous
there were thugs there late at night and
I'm talking about the thugs with the
extra baggy pants tatted up face like if
they read a dictionary they would just
get angry because they don't know how to
read so mind you in that gym I don't
look like I belong the whole night
people assumed that I was a janitor and
[ __ ] it was annoying as hell how many
[ __ ] times I don't work here alright
that boy god damn what well this night
having said [ __ ] it to all the things I
heard about this gym I decided to work
out in my mind I convinced myself there
was no such thing as gang banging past
12 a.m. because you know even to popular
at bedtime [ __ ] so when I get there I
haven't
I know that is back in biceps so the
first thing that I do is I go to the lat
pulldown machine you know that machine
would you just as I finished my first
set and I'm about to start my second I
see this dude walking to the gym and
this is what he looked like he had a bad
tenant pelvis covered half his eyes
tatted up on the arms big ass wife
beater and some baggy ass Dickie shorts
and when I say baggy I'm talking about
baggy to the point where he just looks
like a big ass mistake so as I'm in the
middle of my workout doing the lap pull
downs this dude walks up to me and says
shuffle you're on my machine and at that
very moment in my head I was like what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] do you think you are
talking to me like that [ __ ] take your
[ __ ] but [ __ ] I just saw you walk in
and in my mind I was not gonna let this
fool pug me he doesn't know who the [ __ ]
I am
he don't know what the [ __ ] I've been
through so I spit the [ __ ] on up I look
them directly in the [ __ ] eye and
said you know what this is your machine
I don't get the [ __ ] on out of the way
from that [ __ ] I took my hands off that
bar like that [ __ ] was on fire I was
like nah here you go mr. Otto don't
[ __ ] kill me haha mangle I I was
[ __ ] scared all I can picture at that
moment was if I said no he would have
turned around without his digging to
smack me in the face hello and then what
would happen huh I would have been
forever known as the dude at 24 that had
a [ __ ] mushroom cap [ __ ] mark on
his cheek I don't care what you say
that's not your life on the line how
would you like it if you woke up one day
with a dick in your ass coming out the
mouth but seriously mr. bat though if
you ever see this I wasn't talking [ __ ]
I'm just recollecting a story don't kill
me
love you want me to write that down hey
what is going on YouTube I know you guys
miss these vlogs but sometimes I just
you know I'll get busy and I told you
guys this year that I was working on a
few pilots so that pilot has been taking
up a lot of my time so just to give you
guys a timeline every Sunday all the way
through Wednesday you will have videos
that's right Sunday at 12 p.m. and
Monday Tuesday Wednesday at 3 p.m.
that's right put that [ __ ] in your
calendar living out loud is still
continuing and I'm still doing these
vlogs and every now and then I'll be
doing some sketches so make sure you
guys tune in Sunday through Wednesday
that's the type of [ __ ] I'm doing for
you right now cuz I'm crazy let's
[ __ ] commercial gyms are by far the
biggest greeting greeting ground
greeting ground
so James I dug the fall asleep at a gym
and have an 82 year old man give you
mouth-to-mouth because you thought you
was dead know what me neither you crazy
you know those type of guys that are
always angry for no [ __ ] reason where
they look at their reflection and that's
why the [ __ ] is staring back at
him